because we're so used to
doing for others or how we're taught and
so
finding and there's nothing wrong with
that there are beautiful things that we
get from we get from all of our
experiences too there's dark stuff and
there's light stuff
but what do we hold on to that we feel
expands us and catapults us and what do
we feel weighs us down
or doesn't feel aligned and it's really
hard to tune into that when
you don't know any better you've been
doing it for so long and it just becomes
so
conditioned i believe that each and
every one of us has the power within
ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that
happen i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
so a word that i feel like probably
everyone is dealing with at a high level
and has been dealing with at a high
level in
2020 is change and so i think this is a
great word that you brought up that we
should talk about
and you know we've talked about
transition and some other words and
you made a really good point of how
change is different than transition
and i think that change you know like
you said change is so much more sudden
and um and so i just i think it's a
great word to talk about
i think that it's the most probably
it's probably the biggest thing that
everyone's dealing with whether it's
kids at home work work
losing your job um how you get your
groceries
if you traveled now you're not i mean
there's
so many things that have changed in 2020
and
uh it's you know it's definitely a year
of adapting and so like how do we adapt
to change how do we
feel about change how do we deal with
change and
um you know what is it teaching us
about ourselves when things change
that's great and shoot what's what is it
teaching us about ourselves that needed
to change
yeah because i think 2020 while it's um
you know everybody you know it's like
laugh you come into the year like it's
gonna be perfect year perfect fish
everything's gonna be perfect you know
perfect vision
like all the glasses with the 20 20. but
the thing is
is that it is it actually is like look
at how many
how many truths have been revealed about
you know uh institutions or uh
social dynamics or um relationships
or who we are what we want
um there's been a lot of truths that
have come out
uh i i you know this is a little bit of
a hippie sort of thing to say but
it's uh it's that timelines are moving
so fast right now like it's the idea
that there's
in you know infinite amount of timelines
kind of existing at the same
point at the same time and depends on
what decision you make sort of
transitions into a different timeline
sort of timeline dimension and so we
have we are we are
clearly accelerating through timelines
like things are happening
so fast i mean when you chronologically
go through what the hell has gone on
in 2020 that's true like i mean shoot it
started off with fires in australia
and like that seems like like almost
forgotten at this point in time because
so much has happened
and then you think nothing else can
happen and then the whole state's on
fire and then you know like you can't
it's just been a year so uh you know
is change something uh
that is comfortable free like i mean
has what has changed for you maybe is
maybe more important or
how do you feel about it or what is it
about the word change that you really
why did you mention that you want to say
the word change there's probably
something sitting right there that you
want to talk about
well i mean a lot's changed in my life a
lot's changing with my
um through this this year through this
experience like you said it's
almost forcing people into
[Music]
change i mean there's there was no
choice
in it you know and we had to adapt and
and um from businesses
to families to relationships to
um you know our climate to
uh uncomfortable discussions
and anger and joy and sadness and
confusion i just feel that there
it almost is like a year of
feeling it's super intense
feelings that maybe um not all of us
have been
have been feeling right or ever been
been
asked to feel in this way and it's asked
us to change
and i think that there are things that
are happening and we are changing and i
think there are some things where
it's kind of like we're waiting right
we're just waiting to see which way it's
gonna go
but um things like you know when we were
all quarantined here
you know in the united states and seeing
our blue skies bluer than we had ever
experienced
[Music]
um something that simple
and yet it was i mean i can't imagine i
can always speak on what it felt like
for me
let alone for everyone else what it was
like you know my my stepdaughter is
um moved to asheville north carolina
she's 12 27 years old and she was
alone out there but has a great group of
community of friends so
but we didn't have children in our house
so where they were in school and then
they had to be
um with us i can't imagine what that's
like because i didn't have that so it
was just my husband and myself
um and we were working on a lot of stuff
on our marriage earlier this year in
february
i mean there was a lot of truths that
came through from me
through um the work that i've been doing
and this is a little ahead of the curve
so
little did i know it's like gosh i mean
it literally happened
three weeks afterwards and then and then
you know um kovet really hit us and
shook us and then
you know we had the the closures and but
yeah so
so ben and i kind of had a we were a
little not ahead but we were in some
really uncomfortable space and then we
were like locked together for 30 days
and thankfully we had some of the tools
that we had been working with not only
throughout the years but there was a
brutal time in february where i was
asked
being asked of myself to speak as
truthfully as i can
about all these feelings that i had been
having or that had had
and was burying or holding or not
wanting to acknowledge myself
so we kind of used that time to deepen
our relationship in that vulnerable
space it was asking my husband
um as i spoke those truths in february
it was asking him to do his own work
and not just our marriage therapy and
not just
um his own individual work that he does
through books and and yoga and
meditation his own practice is great but
for him to have someone to work with to
help open him
up in a way um so he and i could
communicate at a new level
um really from his heart we were
very lucky with that because things
could have been very different if we
didn't have that foundation
going into that quarantine because i've
known
so many relationships um of all kinds
that have
changed since we've we had to be home or
since we're not going to work
so there's good and bad i mean there's
there's good things and then there's
people have lost their lives and it's
it's how do we sit in that and how do we
hold the hope
how do we continue to know that every
day is a new day and we just
feel that there is something here that
is showing us something and if you can
take it in that way
um have gratitude um
for having the slower not working you
know for those
those times and being able to kind of
sit and process
but um at the same time you know the
empathy and compassion for those who
have
lost lives and um where other things
have uncovered
themselves like addiction and um maybe
the feelings that we just haven't wanted
to really be and it's like it's
the the discomfort was so extreme
that i think it has brought a lot of
light onto some dark
that was in um whether it's within
ourselves or in our households or
what's happening around um everything i
think that change has
um also highlighted how important it is
to
flow and allow which is something i feel
like we all just really struggle with
you know like we we like our comfort
zones
um we we not only like our comfortable
familiar patterns but we also like our
comfortable familiar
um emotional sort of cocktails that we
um we have when we repeat certain
situations
um over and over again emotionally or
dynamically with people
so um that's probably way too much for
this but um but
we like familiarity and so um i
i know for myself like certain things
that i'll have that have happened this
year that i've done
you know better job of is that when
someone has to
reschedule a podcast or when some trip
gets cancelled
or when someone needs more time for
something
um and they're like oh i'm sorry
xyz this and i go
oh that's okay i'm like it's 20 20.
everybody's doing their best like it
gives you like it's
it's while you know i usually you know i
have this expression
it's a little bit straightforward but
expectations are a [ __ ]
and that's because it's like my stupid
example about expectations
is that um it's flying
there's not a lot of people that just
love flying like i think people can kind
of enjoy like going but
but like to like the experience of
regular flying is
i think it's why it's so bad is because
they almost never exceed your
expectations
i think that's why southwest caught on
because they're like oh wow somebody can
be funny that's great
somebody makes jokes and somebody's
sarcastic that's fun
um but you know i i think that uh
i think that generally when you go fly
like you don't
even if you land early you sometimes
have to just wait for your date
but you like never take off early very
very rarely get you know
get get landed in somewhere like way
earlier than you think other than
you know 15 minutes and so you know you
generally
get what you sign up for so you're only
usually
disappointed there's really not a lot of
opportunity to
have your expectation levels exceeded so
anyway back to expectations our mofo
is that um that we have to learn
how to allow things to change and so one
of the things that i've
actually like wow i mean so much has
changed this year for sure
um for myself like everyone but um
you know i i mean my life is i i'm done
saying this because i don't want this to
really
i mean it my life changes in ways that i
would never expect every couple of years
you've probably heard me say that a few
times yep and it's it has been true for
a very long time and um part of it is
like scary and i don't really want it to
be so dramatic anymore
um but i also think it's because i'm
always
you know there's an allowance for growth
and i'm i i realized i also do
everything fast and i know that sounds
probably pretty stupid because i was a
race car driver
but i do i eat fast i can talk fast i
think fast i get in touch with my soul
fast
i um know truth fast i um
i cook fast like i mean like you
everything i do i do
fat and i process fast and um i
grow fast and so i you know
have had to kind of get a little bit
familiar with change
um because i've had so much of it but um
it doesn't mean that the rate at which
it's happening
this year is comfortable like it's not
right
it's you know because it's just you're
being dropped in the deep end you don't
get a time you don't get you're not
getting time this year
to really be familiar with an
environment before it shifts and
transitions again
or because or before something gets
stacked on top of it
right right like another thing it might
not be that thing changing again but you
just might have another thing to deal
with and so
you know i guess if i'm gonna encompass
like what's the lesson
like this year has been like
i think i've had so many lessons in
empathy is that
to just understand for myself or for
other people
that if things are changing and shifting
you know to just like allow things with
love
and empathy and grace and just
trying to trust that everything that's
meant to come
our way is and you know i mean if you're
being a dick you're probably going to
get bad things but if you're
really trying to practice like you know
being kind and loving which
i think most people are inherently good
then understand that
you know healing and growth and
you know good things are on its way and
just kind of trusting
like a trusting and allowing year right
and we talk a lot about flow and
we've never done that we've done that
word but i think flow could be its own
episode because it's kind of its own
thing
but it's in there right to just allow
instead of so being so rigid with things
why does something have to be one way
right why
start i think that's the thing that's
happening in this search why like
ask yourself why does it have to why do
i have to go to an office i think a lot
of people are like oh wow i can work
from home
you're seeing people leaving big cities
at a rapid rate going to
some some sort of second size cities
third size
cities to you know like have a better
lifestyle and something more affordable
maybe and just
there's people that are like like you
know really a lot like allow
these changes to come into your life and
shine
and just um show you a different way
and it doesn't mean that you have to
stick with it it can go back or it can
take new form
from what it is right now but maybe it's
better
well i think that everything you said is
spot on
i mean expectations just to kind of
circle back to that
um being a [ __ ] it's like i love
it
and it's true because when you put
expectations on things i mean
expectations are different than goals
but our ego likes to use expectations
and so when we do that it doesn't it
creates rigidity
it creates more of like like a
competition
or if it's it allows for more judgment
to come in
because life and this experience that
we're having we are being schooled
majorly that this is not about there is
a fix or expectations or we can hope
we can unite we can come together as a
collective we can do whatever we can we
can empathize more and hold more
compassion
but putting like you know well it better
be here and if it's not we're all doomed
it's like it's just it can put you in
such a space of
fear and i think like
being contracted that you can't flow
um so there's that level and and i think
that
um i just i love that you brought up
expectations because it's something that
i had to let go
of a couple years ago and i wasn't even
aware that i was putting these super
high high level
expectations onto things and when you do
that
it doesn't allow for flow and it is
super rigid and it doesn't allow for
mistakes it doesn't allow for um
um just the humanness and that we are
not supposed to be perfect and we're not
supposed to be getting it right every
time as much as we
want to right on a small or grand
scale of things if we're okay to just be
and be in the discomfort and learn what
lessons are coming through like you said
a lot of people are saying they're
changing their lifestyle
they're moving differently because they
can work remotely um
i wonder what how it's kind of a look on
the corporate side of things with all
the big buildings that we have
oh man yeah i had this discussion with
my dad and i was like i wonder what
they're gonna do with those because
i would think for corporations it would
be more affordable probably to have
some people work from home um you know
and not paying that large overhead um
anyways that's just an interesting i was
just like that's good this is going to
be interesting and
what can we do good with that and dream
in
and have some new um i don't know
just some just just a new way of being
yeah
um so i do think that the the pause
has we've it's asked for change
we are changing whether it's within our
family household in our relationship
dynamics within our work
within our environment changes here and
it's happening and so how do we go about
it are we going to do change with
um rigidity and fear or
being pissed or are we going to do it
and do it as gracefully as possible
with empathy with compassion with
reverence i feel there's a lot coming
through around having just
deep deep respect for our earth and the
planet and all of us as a collective and
that we are
all so different and embracing our
differences and yet
gosh we're not here to be like everyone
else right and we're
supposed to be our authentic selves and
we can unite in that way where there
isn't
that level of i am higher and you are
lower
um so yeah it's brought in
so much around that um and i myself i'm
looking to switch my
my living situation you know that i've
been here for 22 years
um so i'm looking to move to colorado
and and
have been feeling into that and i've
actually been able to have a space to
feel into it because
um because business has slowed down um
for me here i've had the time to feel
into other spaces so that's where i'm
like how can i find the gratitude versus
things have shifted um for the company
that i have
and um what can i do with that and my
mom's my business partner and she and i
just really have been
asked to be truthful with each other and
how we're feeling
within this unknown space and what
direction do we want to go
and and being truthful in that space
with compassion and empathy and
reverence so
so yeah it's it's um changes here
i feel like what we
could each talk about like the
like final idea on change to sort of
make it
good is to just simply talk about
perspective and so we have the ability
to look at something and this is why
stories old old stories imagine
how much they change but then when you
realize that you and i
could be observing the same situation
at the exact the exact same the exact
situation at the same time and you and i
will each have a different story to tell
from it
so that depends on our lens that is our
that is our lens and we all see the
world
through our own private lens
and it's exclusive to you only
and it colors everything that you do
and everything you see and everything
that you experience
and so we have the ability
then to shift that wherever and however
we
we want to or sometimes we need to
and so i think that
what we can do is change
the way that we look at change and and
shift our perspective
to to going because like one of the
things i think that's really sustained
me in my life and allowed as i've said
you know this it's like i've had so much
change
is that i immediately think of it like
oh
[ __ ] and then i think well maybe it's
going to be better than i could ever
expect
yeah because i'm only able to like
i like i mean i'm no different than
anyone else you know familiarity is nice
but
um but but i also have had you know
i also have the perspective that it
could be better than i could ever expect
and since i can't
since i'm not there yet and and let's
say there is the better the better is
coming which it usually is
um let's say that i
i mean i've never experienced that
otherwise i'd know
otherwise i'd be excited about it and so
i think with change it's not
actually that we're so afraid of change
i think that i think that it's actually
more
about mourning the death of what's going
that's true right so with when some
something changes you just
like you can look at it like okay
something like i don't think we're all
so so scared of change it's that we're
afraid i've said we're leaving something
behind
and there is a death happening mm-hmm
and that's so
familiar too so we know yeah well so
that's what that death
oh yeah it's you're losing what we love
familiarity
yeah but what if it could be better and
so
um so you know it's more maybe about
kind of honoring where you've been and
having the perspective that it could be
better than i could ever expect
just start telling yourself that you
know fake it till you believe it i
very much believe that you can do that
and so
um you know we can learn through
repetition so if you just say that to
yourself enough you'll start to believe
it
yeah and um i mean that's how subcon
that's how your subconscious is
programmed
like you know the simple examples like
you know when you're learning how to
walk you have to really think about it
but then you don't think at all how to
walk now once you're an adult because
or much younger than an adult because
your subconscious
subconscious subconsciousness has
programmed it
just like it's programmed how you drive
to work every day
of course that's changed but um but
these are the things that like there's a
lot of things get
programmed and so yeah um we need to
reprogram and you do you know one of the
ways of doing that is through repetition
and so that's why they tell you to do
something for 30 days or six
you know like they like do this for 21
days um
because they want you know it's about
the repetition that helps you to
to make that change it's like rewiring
reprogramming your brain
is what you really need to do so um yeah
so i think that it's really just about
looking at change in a different way
some people look at
change as a good thing and some people
look at it as a bad thing
and um i think we get to choose and
if we can see more of the opportunity
and what is good about change or the
unknown of change
but the good of the unknown right like
we can manifest
if we can whatever that can be and
finding the gratitude
in the change that will support so it's
not like we're totally like it's like
really find those little nuggets
of where can you find those real
tangible gratitude places because those
are the seeds that are going to be
planted that open up the subconscious
to really create that level of like
let's
rewire those neural pathways and and
create a new future that just like you
said
is very unknown to us and what we don't
know can be
extremely scary um so there's a level of
surrender
there's a level of flow letting go of
the judgment
and definitely what you said changing
our relationship
changing our relationship with change
yeah like how we feel about it and if we
can see
that and really have like use you know a
new lens
um i'm being open to sit with that
and also know that we can change again
and change again i mean that's all it's
a part of our free will
is that we have the ability to do that
so um
yeah yeah it's a powerful year
it sure is a powerful year what a time
to be alive that's what i've said so
many times
sometimes i maybe didn't say that so
often but yeah
but it is it is it is it's an incredibly
amazing time to be alive to be alive and
we're all in this together
i'm glad to have you with me and we're
we're
together yeah we do words of the year
every year
uh you started this and um
we've done our words in the past for the
podcast so it's time to do this year's
word of the year
um and i like that it's actually we've
had some time to
um be with it uh
and they're really powerful and so yours
is interiority
which i'm only laughing because i'm like
i remember when you told me about us we
were in hawaii
and you told me about what word you
wanted for the word of the year you were
thinking about and i'm like
what's that mean well i didn't know what
it meant either so i was right there
with you
um how did you pick it how do you pick
interiority
it sounds like an interior designer word
it actually does i didn't even think of
that i mean if i can open my mind around
it but you're very artistic but
um but this came through instagram
through an instagram story
um i follow um
someone called um being as beautiful i
think that's right oh yeah
it is and um kylie yep
yeah yeah anyways she's amazing and she
has such
such light i don't i've never met her or
anything i just i love what she shares
on instagram her words
i started following her recently myself
yeah her healing journey
and she really dives deep into
um feeling and feeling in the body
and in our wounds and in um
enlightenment and in the shadow light
and dark and kind of all of these things
and literally
she was working on if i remember
correctly writing a book
or or a part of a course because she has
a course that she she does with her twin
sister on
um health coach you can become a health
coach so
anyway so i was following her and it was
on her stories and she was kind of had
this diagram
and it was going through all these
things that we would feel
all like into our bodies and things
whether they're triggers
or just experiences but like you know
you feel something from it you have some
sort of reaction
and the center was interiority and it
like
links into interiority and i was like
what is that so interior is at the
middle of the sort of expressions of the
body
it's like getting all the way to the
core it's
yeah it's it's at least in that diagram
when i watch it that's what it was and
so i took a snapshot
um of her story because i knew it was
going to be down and i literally went
into work
that day and showed it to my mom and i
was like i think i found my word
and i said it to her and she was like
what does that mean i'm like
i wasn't sure but i looked it up in the
dictionary and i mean i could feel
i could actually feel what it was and i
understood from what she was describing
like how she was getting to
it but i really wanted to understand the
definition of it
and it really is um our inner self
it's getting into our authentic inner
self it's the essence
our soul are what we like were born with
when we came here what we were before we
were born but then we come into the
human body
so um it's i mean i'm i'm being pretty
literal it's not
soul but it's like [ __ ] like tapping
into
the essence of who we are and so
in order to do that it has a little bit
of a scientific form around interiority
and it's just
really holding space to tap into your
authentic self
and be willing to be present with your
experiences feelings emotions
consciousness
subconsciousness triggers relationships
and being really like holding space
around that and so when i do so when i
heard that
word i thought sketch
that's right up my alley and i wanted to
advance this so i thought that would
really hold me accountable and i thought
it would really because there are times
where i can go into those spaces for my
own inward journey
that that i love and i've been on this
healing journey for quite some time at
least six years
but um but i wanted to go deeper and i
wanted to be more present with it and i
wanted something that had like the umph
that would give me that it's hard to say
a little bit i actually need more
structure
i'm super flowy and fluid and
interiority offered me a little bit more
depth and grounding and structure to
stay tuned
and tapped into that work this is where
we're really opposite because i do so
well i like i
need to like have a format where it
allows me to just like free flow
yeah but what i'm feeling from like or
what it seems like i'm understanding
about the word interiority if i could
maybe even explain it in a way that
makes sense to me
is that interiority is
perhaps you said the word essence but
that's still kind of like a
magical word that we don't really
completely understand
or you know it's not a really common one
like oh that's your essence like
right like but so it's maybe just simply
who you are before
anything imprinted on you before your
parents did anything before any friends
did anything to you any partners did
anything to you it's you before all your
wounds it's like
so you so like it every trigger every
projection
every wound every every every little
thing that happens to us
that's that is undesirable is
linked to the core which is the
interiority
of of it all and so it's about getting
to that right is that yeah really
connecting to your authentic self yeah
so we don't use essence or soul it's
authentic self yeah
i feel it's a tool that supports you to
continue
to say i'm doing my interiority work to
find
and connect to my authentic self and
what is that
because we're so used to
doing for others or how we're taught and
so finding
and there's nothing wrong with that
there are beautiful things that we get
from we get from all of our experiences
too there's dark stuff and there's light
stuff
but what do we hold on to that we feel
expands us and catapults us and what do
we feel weighs us down or doesn't feel
aligned and it's really hard to tune
into that
when you don't know any better you've
been doing it for so long and it just
becomes so conditioned
so yeah so that's that's
what have you learned um i have
my voice i it's been really finding my
voice
and i can't i couldn't use my voice
in the way that i've been able to now
until i did
the true daily practice of my own
interiority work
because then i'm then i'm not speaking
so when we talk about
feeling right like always like if i'm in
my head and then i shut that down and
then i feel from here and i speak from
my heart
but it's um really knowing my
my authentic self and being with her
and feeling her and embodying her
and honestly because it's i kind of drop
in and out pretty easily because i'm not
as
confident i'm not as secure i'm not as
familiar
i'm not um i just haven't
been with my authentic self my whole
life to be honest when i was little
sure but then as i kind of put more
layers on or conditioned and
judged myself and labeled myself
whatever those things are i protect
myself and i become a little bit more
armored a little bit more armored and
i'd act a certain way and be really
polite and kind stacy and empathetic but
but i i kind of lost the
free um fluid just like her
her strength that that i've always known
but i
i i kind of tuned it out because i
didn't feel worthy of having that
um that really that innate
strength that power yeah the power i
thought honestly you had to learn the
power
or you'd have to learn the confidence or
you had to do these things
to build it and they're all real truths
that you need to do those things as well
but when it's your authentic self from
my experience
it is truly like
it's not a learned thing it it is it is
there
and so when you connect from that um
space
then when you speak from that space it
is
different i mean i can ask you that
you've known me for how many years so do
you feel
as i communicate that i'm communicating
more clearly or do you feel that i am
stronger with my words i don't know i'm
asking you're
uh you're more direct
and um
[Music]
you're also a little bit more
confident to be free like i remember in
the very beginning like i used to try
and get you to get drunk so often
and you would not like let go man just
relax
so it's sort of like having the
confidence to just
let go too yeah right as much as
totally you know that i think that was a
thing too for youtube so oh a
thousand percent because of that
perception so i was very used to having
this very
proper good intended that's all real
that's all there
but it what i had put on a disguise
so i couldn't be seen fully because i
didn't want to see myself fully
so it's like how can i even speak from
my authentic self if i haven't
been with my authentic self and how can
i
kind of take those shields off and be
comfortable
in the discomfort and be comfortable in
the parts of myself that
um maybe that i labeled once that still
have their unique quirks
and embrace them and know that it's not
about being perfect it's
actually loving our imperfections and
then we can connect with others in that
way and we're so much
softer and more empathetic and open in
that space and
so kind of as we talk about
letting go when it's a valid point when
you bring that up that how fluid
i i feel myself to be
there for sure in my teens and twenties
um
i was a lot more rigid and controlled
and a lot of that comes from
codependency to control my environment
and control situations
and be that people pleaser and be that
perfect and not get
you know drunk and um allow myself in a
space where so i can feel
um safe and so i can feel that i'm
presenting myself and uh
yeah so it's letting go
so you know as you get more to your
authentic self you need less armor
there's no planning there's no
apologizing there's no it's just kind of
like
you know which was like that first time
that we were at that party and you
called the next day to apologize i'm
like
for what it was awesome
um so yeah i think that that's you know
when we have a deep insecurity we our
ego uh flips it and projects
deep like deep into the other direction
right so if you
you know you didn't want to let go you
kept it really
you you you know you just there's like a
cover-up for it it's the mask
to to not go to the place that you're
scared to go
um totally that's the perfect
so description of it i think i think
what's important though with all this is
that we can
help unpack because this is
it kind of fast forwards the learning
process i think because when we started
this journey it's not like anyone was
like okay so this is what
you know these are some actual ways or
this is my experience for how i actually
get to this place of knowing my
authentic self
instead it was just like reading quotes
reading some books and like listening to
some youtube videos and like
watching super soul sunday and all of a
sudden you're just kind of like i wanna
get more enlightened i want to
expand and you're like it was like you
know you just like
thrown into the abyss but i think it
could be really helpful to
talk about what it what what we've done
to get to know our authentic self mm-hmm
that's the tangible [ __ ] that people can
do something yeah
well otherwise there are a lot of big
words with i agree and it's it's get
down to
what what can we do to support that and
it's definitely not where i sit around
and i'm thinking
i'm going to do and my interiority
worked right right right
right so i i love that you always break
this down so people have tangible
um action plans yeah um so for me
it is getting quiet
it's being able to have space
to connect with her to connect with my
authentic self so
it is for sure journaling it's hiking
it's
i also also allowing myself to do things
that light me up like
what where do i really feel
in my authentic self without even being
in the mind i'm just feeling it and for
me it's nature i'm
always there um when we're together and
we're having these conversations and
being super open and vulnerable
um i feel seen and so surrounding myself
by
my loved ones that i love and i cherish
those support this type of work it can
also be some people might not understand
it and that's okay
and so that's where we can get clear to
have some boundaries
um because this work does take some solo
practice
and it does take community as well so
for me therapy
for sure has always been a part of my
practice having someone that i can talk
to that can reflect back that actually
isn't connected to anyone in my family
or anyone in my life they're just
literally there
holding that space um and then
as you know we talked about dusty but
i've done some beautiful body work
i work with adam and elisa doing the
soul work which has been a lot
of finding and connecting to that higher
self like my soul and my voice which
also allows me to
feel and be with my authentic self um so
all that work i've been doing for about
six years and then i continue to add on
to it um
sadie you've done a lot of work with
sadie adams out in venice beach
she's incredible she does a lot of
energetic work for me it's
these are things that have helped me
break down a lot of the
uh the hard hard armor i put on that i
wasn't even aware of i could say
oh yeah i put that up or i was trying to
act or be a certain way
but the armor is so protected
um and you're just not aware you're
doing it so the layers just continue to
come
the ego acts so much faster yeah in the
soul
right yeah so it's like constantly
coming to
coming into action before there's a
chance for anything to be caught so
it's a it's an effort to get past the
ego it's
it's a huge effort and also to be in
that space and notice when your
ego is coming into play and notice so
we've talked about fear before and so
fear for me that's something sadie
taught me is to use fear as my teacher
to and fear for me always was for me to
retreat like in my turtle shell like
you don't go into that you know you
don't look at it um
and be with it and that is a huge tool
and i know it's simple it's not even an
action i mean it's an action of us just
being with a feeling
and it's the fear and sitting with that
and so my first experience of fear is
typically it'll go to like a triggered
or
a wounded space maybe where it's coming
from or an insecurity
um and i acknowledge that i just
acknowledge it and you can either
journal this through or you now i'm at a
space where i'm kind of like
i can feel it and i see oh that's where
that's coming from from when i was
younger
or just being insecure and then i go
into
the depths of it and then i use the fear
and i'm like oh i'm just
being nervous how i'm going to look or
if i fail
or what people are going to think and
now i get to choose what do i do with
that do i move forward
or do i choose not to but normally
before i just would just
shut it down and typically now i always
say like just move forward meaning like
you just didn't participate in it or you
just like withdrew
yeah wow kind of like our slipknot
so our friend steph had a slip and slide
in her backyard for
her boy she's three boys and you run at
it and you have your
you have your little tube and then slide
on your belly land in the pool
and you know boys are ripping around i
grab the inner tube like ready ready
here we go
oh and you run up to the slip and slide
of the first it took a while to get
moving and then you run up to it
and you stop at the beginning of the
slip inside you're like no no no i'm not
gonna go
and you back up and you go again and
then you end up getting it but we're all
i mean
yeah like and you i think you were kind
of like
you know you were vulnerable enough to
go there and show that you were like a
little scared and to even just say you'd
do it in the first place
but um but uh what i also wanted to
wanted to make sure that you knew that
day was that not to
feel bad in fact to feel like the brave
one because that was not hard for me
yeah you faced it it was well i mean
it's beautiful i don't know if i aced it
but i had no problem
doing it so right meaning it was not
hard for me
yeah so like you're there feeling like
oh my i'm sorry i'm like no no
that was hard for you okay that was way
more brave than what i did
yeah well thank you because i appreciate
because you actually felt into me then
and you know me so well and you're like
i get that this is this is a different
level for stacy than it is for me and
that's you just empathizing and just
really being in tune
and and yet it was so fun and it was so
free
and i mean i literally not only did i
end up
you know i ran stopped turned around
because i felt like i didn't have enough
speed to go
so then i redid it and then i actually
landed on the slip and slide and i got
all the way to the end and i didn't make
it in the pool
and okay that was even more funny
because i it was actually being okay
with that
you know because my fear is not really
what's going to happen on the slip and
slide it's like if i just make my a
complete fool of myself
and you want what i did and you all were
cheering me on and it was fabulous
yeah so thank you yeah yeah but
those are simple simple things where i
notice
for myself um really how i've altered
who i
am and how i i am not being authentic in
some it's
i'm really unconscious to it and the
more um
attention i'm paying attention to like
the more space i'm holding around it for
myself the more i notice it
in little things it can be big things
but it also can be little things
so there's a freedom that comes well
it's when we
um can start to um nurture
those triggers and projections and start
to like
get rid of them essentially right like
to be able to live with them and not be
triggered and not project we then make
more space for
love and empathy and play and play
enjoy exactly because you spend less
time
less time protecting yourself
um like by being triggered and then
projecting
or protect you know or like not
withdrawing or whatever it may be
or causing a problem whatever your
whatever whatever it is that you do
and you just have more room to see the
other person for who they are instead of
like you instead of it just being about
you like oh you made me feel like this
it's like
you didn't make nobody nobody made you
feel any one way so then you just are
seeing them
yeah you're exactly and that is such a
gift because this
is doing our own work
around finding our authentic selves
healing um self-love all these terms
right that are out there
it's so big because though it seems
so much about us as individuals
and energetically it literally
shifts everything around you so our
relationship has
upgraded um all of my my relationships
with my
family with my husband with our friends
as we go through this journey and we
become more vulnerable
and we feel more and we're more
comfortable being goofy or saying things
that we don't know how
it's going to be received but
being there naturally as you see me
you're like oh stace
i actually see you more because you're
you're be you can tell
there's something that's not here it's
an energetic
presence that from soul to soul that
we're here
and we're together and so it's a really
beautiful thing to see the upgrades that
happens not only for ourselves but
but everyone around and some people
some things also might fall aside so
some
relationships will elevate and some um
might not and that's also okay too
there's no room for
you know as we get more connected to our
authentic selves and we have more
boundaries and we speak our voice more
um it might not be aligned with people
that we've always had or some people
might just need some space from it
it's just experiences that i've had for
myself
through this process like my sister and
i um
haven't have a great relationship but i
do find that we
are treading a little bit
lighter so we make sure that we can hear
each other as we're in our own
healing journeys and we're both kind of
working and feeling versus trying to
understand i know i
am with her and so that's an example of
that and just knowing that that love is
is always there but it's okay to have a
little space if needed
yeah what we're doing i think that um
i think that we do a lot of the same
things when it comes to self-practice to
create that awareness about who we are
as our authentic self
um but i i guess i would just like quite
simply just state that
i
i believe that relationships are
necessary
to help us to realize where our
weaknesses are
aka triggers and where we project and
where we
put our shield up put our armor up so
relationships
are an integral part of it and that's
why they say especially like your
partnership like your
your husband or your wife or your
boyfriend or girlfriend
that usually is the the most um
beneficial partner to learning these
things
um but i i would also say just from my
experience is that
i i think that um
you know it can be done in partnership
for sure but it's going to take
a little i would say it might take a
little longer
and it's going to take some efforted um
solo time so it's to
have someone shine the light through
being the mirror for you
from being the person so so that can
help you recognize
you know where you get triggered and
when you project and
um but then to be able to you need the
space that's all i'm gonna say is that
you really need some solo time to be
able to
unpack it to be able to know who you are
right like i think that's the most
important thing is you just know who you
are know what you'd like to do
know what you're willing to put up with
know what you're what you deserve
know what um your rhythms and patterns
throughout the day are like how do you
like your day to even go
and you know you you tend to you know
become your more authentic self when you
do those things more often and then let
that energy
accelerate yeah
i love to ask people the question
what do you think we're here for like
what's the point of all this
and i my answer at this point in time
because
i'm open-minded i'm always willing to
allow that to change
uh is um i've said that i think that
we're here as
humans to experience duality
that since we have choice um
sort of the choices that uh
create our reality and um there's a
learning
process and so
you know the spectrum being obviously
like all the way from
you know bliss and joy and happiness and
love to grief sadness sorrow
shame regret anger envy
like to really feel both ends of the
spectrum
and i think that as i have
opened up more opened my heart more felt
more
i my my duality window
is widening like if you don't if you
stay
safe all the time and protect yourself
you never end up getting to feel
like real true connection and joy
you also don't you because you're trying
to save yourself
from the misery yeah right even though
people that sometimes
sort of almost make themselves miserable
or like like
reside in some low-level misery it's
because they've also told themselves
i think that that if they stay there
then it won't get worse
right like i don't want to allow myself
an evil level of vulnerability because i
don't want it to get any worse than here
so
i think that i think that as we get more
open and vulnerable and as we get more
connected with our true self and connect
with other people
um we uh
we we feel a bigger window of that and
so
you know for me so the word i want to
talk about is duality because
we were with the words we were going to
do i was like i wanted to do joy
and then but joy is basically what for
me i
felt all the way from i would call i
would say
grief to joy have been you know
i mean grief doesn't even seem to
justify how awful it's kind of been at
times but
um but joy does where there's just these
moments where
you know i've felt like the simplest
and in the simplest things have felt
like the deepest level
of connection and happiness
and joy and like contentment
almost like there's a there's a level of
feeling so content
so great so much gratitude and just like
a little bit more of an overwhelming
amount of love than normal
and um like a real like transcendence of
energy and feeling and emotion um
but i don't think that i would have got
there without
sort of the opening and without being on
the other side of things and so
you know duality is this thing where i
think that we're you know again
maybe the maybe the root of what what to
talk about is like this
this idea that we need to keep ourselves
safe and so
as i'm like saying that i'm trying to
get i need to get used to
i need to get used to my word of the
year like acclimate to it
because as frustrating and sad as it is
that i'm fee
that there's been so much grief and and
i remember journaling a while back and i
was
um sort of doing some soul journaling
as we do and asking my higher self or my
soul my
inner child whatever you want to call it
like will i ever
feel better well will this go away
and um the answer was no and i was like
um
and then quickly came in which doesn't
usually happen but like
a question but it was kind of part of
the answer of like no
you won't feel better about this
but the other side of it was but aren't
you feeling more joy now too
and the answer was of course yes i am
and so it's kind of getting comfortable
being uncomfortable and continuing to
expand what that
is right oh yeah well we can spend a lot
of our time in life
trying to to keep things comfortable
which kind of seems like that's why
we're here we're
we're here to do better and we're here
to make everything perfect and
everything should look a certain way and
feel and be a certain way
but that in itself has its own rigidity
and like not
authentic space to be in and so when i
think the truth is shown to us which
typically will always come through
because that's not reality
right living in perfectionism living
just in the
perfect comfort right like the
in-between um
because because if you're only in that
space and you're never growing
right evolving and in order to grow and
evolve we have to be able to feel the
pain
you know we have to be able to be in the
light but also be willing to be in the
dark
and see what that is and feel what that
is and feel it with others and and
um and most importantly ourselves and
and
hold space for it without
like severe shame and everything that's
going to keep us
to go back into that perfect exterior
like what do we do to keep everything
looking so perfect on the outside
so no one knows even though i feel this
and then the shame just eats away at you
and
i mean it's just amazing so yeah so you
to be in such a vulnerable space
to be allowing yourself to process the
feelings
from the beautiful to the extreme joy to
the
depths of deep deep deep grieving
um being brave enough
to be in those two and the duality of it
is what's giving you a whole new
perspective
and i feel just a level of reverence
for us being here for for being human
and not only from our experience but
from everyone's experience
um there is a that there see
this seems to be here for a reason and
we're feeling it at numerous times
including what's happening right now
in this year um there's extreme
discomfort
and there's extreme duality that's being
shown
so um and what do we do in those spaces
do we react
or do we sit with it do we journal do we
do
do we allow ourselves to process the
feelings and know that these are our
feelings and it's okay to have
right so it's so much of that is so
different than us trying to
not feel trying to hide it from other
people trying to not react and project
onto other people
also so um yeah i think it's a really
good
a good word to sit with and talk about
and feel into
because um we don't realize
when we're not able to see the duality
and be comfortable to be in it
how how we can show up and how we can
react
and how we limit ourselves sure and how
we see other people in those spaces
so a couple things that came through for
me
at the very beginning with all of this
grief which you were a
first-hand witness for um
i remember one of the first things was
understanding how
like it gave me insight into humanity
by allowing myself to grieve that deeply
and feel that deeply
yeah um some of it was allowed some of
it was forced
but um sometimes we have to be thrust
into stuff
um is that like one of the things was i
remember
uh feeling like um you know one of the
things that
i always uh you know i'm very you know
self-aware of my body and you know with
food and fitness and
i remember like i can be a little
judgmental in that area then because i
judge myself that way
and so um i remember
you know not being able to eat and
feeling really
so so sad and so uncomfortable and
grieving so much and then
uh i remember having this new
perspective now when you look at
bodies and like i was losing weight but
i didn't want to look in the mirror
because i'm like this isn't like i
didn't want this
to happen like i'm this is from sadness
not from like discipline or hard work or
happiness right
and so i remember thinking to myself
this is like a little in like
it was like an opening for me and
empathy to go
you know maybe you just didn't look at
everyone that looks the way you think
you want to look
because what it takes to get there might
not be what you want
right so sometimes behind someone that
you see
might be a lot of sadness might be
unhealthy habits or um disorders or
uh of an issue maybe they're sick
right you have no idea what it is but to
understand it like gave me that
that insight into the fact that you know
not everything is as it seems
that's not actually nothing as it seems
exactly
so to have a little bit more love and
compassion in that area
and then the other one was just feeling
the level of sadness that i had
again because it comes through this like
extreme duality
um i'm feeling literally like
i can be you know me i can be like
i'm super direct and i'm also like we'll
just suck it up buttercup like get
it together just try harder like you
remember me birthing
that saying try harder yeah which is a
good one for a lot of stuff but um
but um but i remember
feeling so much sadness and i felt
literally like
no hope like i was at i had like it and
i it was the worst day of my life
it was the day we got home from the trip
and like i was the worst
i i mean i'm not even i will not be able
to articulate
like you like you saw me but like it
wasn't it was like
it's like i can't even give you i can't
even give you a
total feeling as to how it was but it
was the worst it was literally the worst
day of my life
and um just like no hope that was the
other thing no hope and so
in that moment i had the insight into
understanding
how people would you know i have an
incredible support team
i have so many loving people and so much
so much good in my life like i really
have an amazing life
and so much and so it was like wow but
if you
imagine like if someone didn't
and they had less or less friends or
less means or less
you know space to deal with or like
whatever like less
than i had like how you can see how
people
don't want to keep going yeah like i
think someone said to me like
um call me to make sure like call me if
anything happens like i think they were
seriously worried about me being
you know uh you know doing something
really silly and direct and
like very not silly not the right word
they probably were worried about me
doing something
um out of character that was in light of
like
because of my sadness and um so you kind
of got an insight into
suicide and to you know the other things
that people would do
to feel something or to get out of it
and so
you know those are sort of the things
that i might be able to be you know a
little bit more judgmental in the past
about
but like so through the duality
came a lot of empathy for sure when you
get to experience that
yourself yeah it allows you
to have a whole other experience that
there's no room for judgment echoes out
the door
it's like when it is your experience
um it's a reality check
like no other and um
[Music]
i remember that day very very well
and you were in a very very vulnerable
space
but you were asking and you were
you were
you wanted to be and you wanted to
to be in the uncomfortable space you
wanted
it's not that it was almost like i don't
it was no more answers it was just
kind of it was it was a very like
even though i was so sad you were so um
[Music]
open it's it's
like you said it's very hard to
articulate um and you even bringing this
up here is
is i can tell you can feel me yeah i'm
like whoa
stays keep it together we're not going
to put the water on
yeah i'm selling that to myself and i
think you're just you're feeling me too
um so it's very courageous of you to
share this because there are so many out
there who have been
in um including myself in moments of
deep despair where hope does not feel
at all obtainable and
for someone in your um
life and your capability and and just
everything that you embody to be so
open and to share that you had you
felt this level that also opened you up
to a whole another level of empathy but
that you
you you were in it and you called your
support
st team what you needed you know you
vocalized to me
we spoke to haley you were with your mom
that you talked to your mom like you
you made and that's what's important in
these times is um
as much as we talk about solo when we're
i feel like
in our dark dark dark places like in a
lot of our shadow stuff that we're doing
to make sure that we have a support
system whether it's a therapist a best
friend
um your parents anyone who you trust um
that it's okay to ask for help because
everyone is here
with an open heart and open arms with
love
and i think that was
very big for your healing and has
opened so much for you through your own
experience it showed me that too it
showed me it showed me what it means to
hold like
to hold space for someone it showed me
what it means to
you know put yourself totally aside and
um it gave me i like very rarely
really want to put myself where i'm very
people pleasing codependent right so
to just let people just take care of me
was
uncomfortable too so it made me realize
that it's okay
like to do like i had to have it but
then
it gave me more comfort to ask for help
and then
um it also showed me what it what it
means and
you it was demonstrated how to do it
which i don't think because i've not
asked for it i also don't know how to do
it does that make sense
right so that that expanded like i'm
sure that i'm not a total dick right so
i think i'm not a total dick so
you know when you like again it's kind
of pushing those boundaries like i take
carry little
like you know it's like you know i've
just expanded my ability to have
hold space and have empathy as well as
ask for what i need and allow
right so like those got pushed too so
it's like and there it's a really useful
range like imagine like okay here's a
funny little like analogy
so we see and we hear in the
very smallest spectrum right like of the
total spectrum
of all the all the sort of ultraviolet
rays like gamma rays whatever
we see a tiny tiny little bit and the
same thing with hearing
and so um imagine now that
what if we got to tap into what if we
could see infrared
right what if we could hear uh
what if you could hear these crystal
balls right now that are actually
singing in the background as we talk
because
our voices are our energies hitting them
like they
um you know what if you could hear that
what if you're what if you're what if
all these things
expanded and to me that is how it feels
with this with duality is that like
you're getting to experience
being a human on a much
grander scale on a much grander scale
and i think that
i think that being able to feel and for
us to experience duality and to have
an emotional body is part of why we're
here as
be as human i mean there is an emotional
intelligence to that
but we're more taught about our mental
intelligence or that's more
celebrated or more of like the goals
again
nothing wrong with that but where is our
emotional intelligence and how come that
isn't celebrated in that way and that's
where therapy
and a lot of this this work in school
the interiority that we're doing
right exactly is is being able to have
that emotional intelligence and it's not
to ace it or to win it everyone's
experience is different everyone's
emotional intelligence is different but
i i feel it's why we are here as humans
to have that it's
it's another level of sensitivity that
literally too
high to attunes us to everything that
you were just talking about
so when we when we get our armor down
and when we go into these very
vulnerable spaces and feel the depths of
despair
it cracks you open to a whole new level
that we've never experienced the only
thing i can think of and i i don't know
because i don't remember being born
right like i mean i don't remember being
born but i would think that level of
like
what is this that you're coming into
sure right
um so you we experience this as adults
through um relationships and careers
and our our own expressions and our own
mistakes and whatever that is
to not be afraid or shamed by it but to
be grateful that we're
able to be in this space and and feel it
and be with it and know that that's here
so we can grow and expand
so we can raise our emotional
intelligence
that's what i'm hearing from you what
happened from not just the whole
experience but that day
is that there was a depth of empathy and
not just for others but for yourself
yeah exactly and and that's raised you
to a whole new connective
level that you're having with everyone
that you're around
including as simple as plants and life
and the sun and the moon you know it's
like yeah you're feeling
at a new there's a new sensory that um
you've allowed yourself to be to be
fully fully vulnerable in that space
yeah and you've done great things to
continue your practice
as you're stepping into this rawness
that's
um been a bit unknown to you at this
level emotionally
and you've added things that's giving
you support yeah
which is huge and that's what we're
talking about you know to help people
too is like
you know what is it that you do yeah you
feel supporting you in this space as
you're kind of like a newborn baby
emotionally right as you would say birth
thing you always talk about everything
yeah yeah um well are you asking me yeah
oh
um uh i mean
i actually would say that one of the
things that i'm trying to do a good job
of
is because i understand because i've
been on uh
um sort of processing and unpacking so
much
uh of sort of the traumas and again
every time i say that word i feel like i
have to say they don't have to be like a
car crash or someone dying trauma is
just like
some emotional imprint from something
that happened in your life could be
small could be like a guy breaking up
with you
and something he said and you never
forgot like it could be
you know it doesn't have to be big um
it could so anyway um i feel like
because i've had to do so much
because there's so much work around that
for me and understanding
so trying to identify patterns why
why i have patterns certain patterns in
my life um
and why i'm triggered in certain ways
and what i'm projecting i think
um you know why i'm projecting
that i want to keep
the i want to keep everything at the
surface as much as possible so i keep so
i keep
up with it so i i you know
meditate in the morning sometimes
journal or sometimes only journal so
meditation journal in the morning
and then um uh you know
doing sort of that somatic you know
breath
like somatic sound work to try and
process emotions so i do that with the
class or
sometimes with bodywork and um uh
and doing a lot of things that i love to
do that keep me enter
keep my energy up and keep me positive
and keep me
so it's a lot about identifying
when you feel good so that you can
identify when you feel
bad yeah right right so
it's because i think it can get a little
murky
like to understand like when you
actually feel good when you feel bad
so when you do things that you that's
why being alone really does kind of help
because you're only taking care of you
um is that you know we're very much only
taking care of you
that during that time you you're only
doing kind of whatever you're just doing
whatever you want to do and so once you
start to
do that more and more you start
realizing what it is that makes you
happy and so
um identifying the difference between
what feels good and what doesn't feel
good
is part of the duality understanding how
it feels in your body then is kind of
like
you know it's a big step but it's next
level to understand how it
resonates in your body if you feel like
um a tension a tightening
an apprehension a fear versus
like an excitement and a hope and like a
like a longing or a
ah like a pleasure or like joy from it
or an excitement level like
understanding the difference so it's
just kind of
yeah i think i think it's you know
there's so many little things along the
way but
you know meditation journaling breath
um sound nature
a lot of the same things that you do
yeah um i think are all really
and then just really like doing learning
yourself
so that you can and what about are you
working with someone to support you oh
yeah
yeah i do online therapy i do talk
therapy
um so yeah yeah i've done like online
courses
bring in that third party yeah because a
lot of the self stuff is
wonderful and great yeah but to be able
to support
for me a lot of the emotions that come
through that yeah it takes having that
third place
um therapy wise to help yep someone
objective
i agree yeah you're right and i also
it's a good dimension just because
yeah it's funny i remember talking to my
mom about um
you know this summer because again like
here i am i'm packing all this [ __ ]
and so i remember asking if she ever
thought about doing therapy with dad
ever
and she was like oh no no no
and it was like the response i guess i
probably thought i'd get but
it was such a big response and then she
was like well does i mean
it's not that i i wouldn't it just like
that's just not something that we did
and
it was just like back you know decades
ago
it you only went if you were like
had real problems like you were addicted
to something
or you had some like maybe it was like a
much more of a what we would think of as
a trauma like
rape or um you know child molestation
or something like that right or some or
you were weird i think that that was
also maybe just like part of what people
thought that you went to therapy for
um a lot was kept private
yeah yeah that was kind of swept under
the rug yeah and
our our family business is no one else's
business so
yeah so you don't share in that way
and i just think it's a cultural change
that is happening that's
thankfully that's being asked where it's
more open that therapy is a beautiful
beautiful thing it is essential
it elevates everybody's relationship
including with yourself but with
everyone around you but
i would say that with my mom also she
can go to therapy with my dad
and um yet she's been so supportive with
me
and is so curious and always asked my
face she went to therapy with me
um and uh uh it's just so good and my
husband and i are big on that too
for our relationship but for mine sololy
it's um
such an important thing i'm grateful you
shared that because i just think that
that's
it's it's unpacking the fact that it's
not this idea or like
it's a shameful thing yeah it's a very
healthy medicinal way for us to and then
also
like to sort of like
wrap up kind of the things that you can
do to sort of
nurture take care of and and learn how
to deal with the duality that's
happening in your life
if you're allowing yourself to really
open up there there can be some
some things that you really wish you had
a chance to talk about or have some
objective for
um is um
the the idea
that so i went to therapy way back in
the day
when i was married which people don't
even know that about me really some
people don't
know that but was for a long for for
seven years
and went most the whole time
and i got a little jaded on it like
[ __ ] therapy like probably stayed too
long you know like
um or you know i just kind of thought i
don't want to deal with that i don't
have to do that anymore
and so didn't do it for a long time
but it goes that but but what i think is
really critical
that your mom said to you
that i ended up like that i ended up you
know realizing for myself
is that therapy doesn't need to be
to like process whatever's going on in
your relationship yeah i can be a part
of that but way
better than that because the the you
can't change someone way
better than that is the inside job on
yourself and understanding
how you're contributing to the problem
because you are
1000 and so your mom said to you what'd
your mom say
to you because i realized that like
screw therapy for
to like talk about someone else that's
[Music]
that's when you have anyone else in the
picture other than yourself you can't
guarantee a fix
yeah you can only guarantee the fix if
it's you
and you're in control you've only got
you you've only got you
yeah so i had been going for gosh a
couple years
and and my mom would i mean there were
some intent there were times where it
was for
um my marriage and my family i have a
beautiful stepdaughter and
we were working on that family dynamic
um so it was a lot on
on on making sure that that was a
healthy space
for everybody involved but they were
definitely i mean mom being my mom she's
also my business partner so
um she sees everything but she's super
in tune with me and
she's well how was therapy i'm like well
we've learned this and it was good and
we're applying this and we're working on
that and she was like
so when do you work on you
[Music]
and i was like well maybe next time
and literally i would go and i was
saying
i will make that a point but there was
kind of so much going on and this is not
it's just i actually changed therapists
there was so much that was going on in
our dynamic we really needed like a
family
therapist but it was very supportive but
i needed a solo
therapist for me and so the same would
happen but when are you going to work on
you stays but
okay that's great but when are you going
to work on you because she could tell
mom she's just seeing me she is she
isn't i mean she definitely
is the backbone that gave me the courage
yeah um to do that
other life circumstances within the
marriage and things where it just
literally forced it to get a new
therapist and to
um so speaking of you know the duality
right that showed itself and that's when
i finally got a therapist for myself and
started working on me and it wasn't
about
saving my marriage it was about saving
myself yeah and finding out where i lose
myself and my self-worth
because i was trying to be something so
not me you've only got you
and you've got you you just have to
learn how to you too
learn how to nurture that we're doing it
so my word of the year
is feel so
as you know like i totally
wanted to change my word of the year
from feel to something else because i
was
feeling so much and then we decided
actually you recommended it you said
i don't think you should change your
word of the year i think you should
add something to your word of the year
so
i changed it to feel joy because i was
really sick of feeling like [ __ ]
so um feel you are like the ultimate
feeler
i feel like i feel like you should talk
about feel
i do i think you should because you know
we did that
um podcast with alisa and adam
and um for their holy human um podcast
if anyone wants to listen to that
and yours was on you know we talked
about you being an empath a lot
and i was super educated and so
i feel as though that's kind of what
it's implying when you feel is that
you're really connecting with your body
and you're you know getting more
information about the situation
than using your head
you're spot on so yeah talk about
feeling like truly feeling well i think
for me truly feeling because it's
something i've always
i've always been in tuned with um
but labeled being too sensitive um
[Music]
so it's interesting as i've become older
to really
accept it as a gift versus being um
feeling like really sheltering myself
around it because when you feel so much
um it's not only words and actions of
people but we feel energetically
and um it also can get a little bit
confusing
just in the normal navigation of being
human
and like going to school because we're
using our minds so much and we're taught
academically
to be using our minds so much and going
into those things
um versus actually
which is important we need balance but
when you're in a space where you can
really
feel and you're tuning out from the mind
and what we think
preconceived um ideas are or how people
are
thinking of us it really helps us feel
into
being present with someone and being
present with yourself and
and it can take time to learn how to do
that like for you because you're so
strong and you're so determined and
you're so driven um and you use your
mind so much so as you're
bringing your word of the year in as
feel it helps you
um and you'll have to tell me if this
feels right for you but just
pause a little bit have a little bit
more patience and feel
into experiences that are happening for
you
and i always say i think we mentioned
our last podcast it's
you know instead of listening from the
mind it's you know
feeling from our heart and what is that
heart guidance that we're feeling
so um it takes a little bit of practice
and for me
i've had to use um
accepting feeling as a gift but then
also knowing that it doesn't mean that
i'm not intelligent and because because
because it goes slower right is that
what makes you feel less intelligent
yeah i'm not as quick to answer on
things i i
feel into if you're asking me where
should we go to dinner or what should we
do
it takes me a little bit and i pause to
check in to see what
feels comfortable for me where normally
if i was really connected and up here
and things were firing quickly
i should definitely be able to answer
quicker and kind of
tune in you kind of you know you
casually say
feel into but that's not very
descriptive
like that's not super helpful for
someone who's like
oh so think about it you know what i
mean like feel into
is different than think about mm-hmm
explain what the difference is for you
when you say feel into it like what is
the actual process that's happening
that allows you to tap into more of the
emotional
body and the more of how the body feels
versus what the mind is thinking
yeah or do they they do you need them
both and it's uh
you know like when we're talking to adam
and elisa it was like there's a
the delay can be the difference between
it entering
as a thought like oh you already want to
go to dinner
and then you have a check-in process
through the body
that a lot of people bypass or have
never learned to use
yeah i think you described it
beautifully
because i do have a conditioned mind and
a conditioned way of being
due to being so sensitive and feeling so
deeply at a young age
that my mind will be the first thing to
come in
and as elisa says like the little
gremlins and say
um is that going to make that person
happy um
that kind of goes into codependency
stuff that i'm working with um
on myself anyways but you need to yeah
it's like we we understand that so my
mind can kind of go into that so would
that feel good for danica would that
feel good for my dad would that feel
good for my mom if we're looking on
deciding where are we going to eat or
whatever
vacation wise and so i'll i'll get a hit
right from my mind that comes in
and a lot of it is um that those the
conditioning and my subconscious and so
to kind of tap
out of that um i can hear it
it gets busy and i just i mean you'll
notice i'll close my eyes and i kind of
just
yeah pause and right then the minute
that i allow
to feel in that way and so it's going to
be different for everybody yeah
not everyone needs to close their eyes a
lot of the times you're going to be able
to hear stuff and then
just it's going to come through you can
be that direct which i think you can be
it can be super
intentional like you can switch to know
from here to here
so i think it's of having awareness of
when we notice when our mind's coming in
and are we choosing from our mind
because that's natural that's how we're
taught from a young age
um and then we can choose to stay in
that space we can choose to balance it
with
with feeling our guidance and feeling
energetically what does that really feel
like from
our authentic self versus pleasing or is
it the right thing to do
or afraid of what judgments might come
in if i say the wrong thing these are
all things that i've had
i've had from being so sensitive so all
the labels i've given myself
kind of funny you gave yourself yeah
they were they were my labels that i put
on
um i'm dyslexic so i have a learning
disability and
uh there are numerous things like i
didn't do well in school i was really
challenged with
um books i did really well hands-on
but with tests and things like that it
was very challenging for me so
there were a lot of things where i
wasn't fitting in or falling
into the norm so i gave myself these
houses yeah this school can make us feel
like that because i think a lot of
people can probably relate either
someone you know listening that went to
school or have kids in school it's like
you know my kid it's like no it's not
that i'm not bright
or they're not bright it's just that
that just because i don't fit into this
box of what you're considering smart
does not mean i'm not yeah i'm very
lucky that my mom was
really yeah she could tell that
my sensitivities were a gift she could
tell that the compassion
and the softness that i had there was
something special and i'm really
artistic and creative
my sister's wonderfully book smart i
mean
so inspiring incredibly athletic and um
those are all things that are don't come
naturally for me like my hand eye
coordination
and um so it's such a different
space and and navigating and being young
and getting into high school and just
kind of evolving from that and then into
a career space
and how can i use my gifts and not feel
hindered by it
and um it's just it's been a very
interesting process and
i think for school what's great is there
are a lot of different types of um
schools you can go to that actually tap
into people that are more creative that
are more naturally like
super feeling based which is how they
can express so much through art
um written words and poetry and um there
are schools that are great for
really academic based where your mind is
turned on and needs to be challenged
so you know i think that they're working
on creating more of a variety of schools
for people
and so to have parents that can be in
tune with
i notice that my daughter or my son is
um struggling in this this way what my
mom always did was check in with me and
what is that because i was always a cd
student so um i was very lucky that i
didn't get punished they always held me
accountable to rates might raise my
grades up
but they also um my mom just
i didn't know that she i didn't know
that yeah yeah
and it's no wonder why you have like why
you want to give yourself labels like i
you know i'm i'm with dyslexia like i
have a learning disability and that's
why i didn't do
you know that's no wonder but i mean you
have excelled in
so many other areas that um you know
i love the idea of i read something
where it was like don't take score too
early
and i was like oh god that's so great
right because in life i want to go we
want something and then we didn't get it
or
you know this isn't working out but then
you know fast forward x amount of time
later all of a sudden you go oh i'm so
glad that work that
worked out like that and it's you know
similarly if
school's a struggle like don't take
score too early and
call yourself something or or concede
yeah how many people concede and just
say like well you know i guess i'm just
not smart i'll just take this job
instead of feeling into what it is that
they love
so for me you know i i think that
feeling at you know
young age is probably overwhelming and
there's probably a lot of people that
listen like
are like this and you know they had a
hard time and felt really emotional i
think that's the crazy one that i've
started experiencing as i feel more this
year
is that you i have a hard time telling
the difference
uh sometimes between my emotions and
someone else's emotions
like all of a sudden i'll just get this
wave of anxiety which i
which i've never had anxiety in my life
or this wave of sadness or something
like that and i'll be like
where's this coming from and the
i will say too this is like something
kind of interesting too is that you
don't always have to be with the person
for it to happen
yeah understanding that uh you know if
you get a little bit more into
the sort of the quantum realm like and
entanglement and all kinds of other big
words that are like way out there in
science
um it's uh quantum science um that
it's you know we have entanglement with
people and we we are connected
energetically with
you know well if you believe in the
saying that we're all one
then we're connected with everything
which is why maybe you can watch a
you know field of trees get plowed down
and actually go like ah that's so
sad who cares you're not gonna climb
that tree
right you're not you're not hanging out
in that woods but like you have a
connection but it's more strongly of
course like you can feel that a lot with
um with people and so
i've been feeling that too where i'm
like where did this energy from and
realizing that i'm i'm at times maybe
feeling someone else and not myself and
so
i'm starting i need to learn the
difference between like what's mine and
what's theirs which no wonder why if
this happens to you when you're a kid
like very freaking confusing
right i mean super confusing to go to
school to be around people
and you know you seem like a basket case
or like you know
recluse and totally that would be me
i really stayed home because i didn't
feel that i fit in anywhere
and so i felt very safe in my nurtured
space and
um could be free to express myself and
be
and and felt a lot more expressive in
that way
um but again those are conditions that i
that i also put on myself i mean i was
never
kind of told to be that way it's just
where i felt i could breathe and where i
could be
um so i agree i think that also what
you're
feeling with your word of the year with
with feel
is you're starting to really tap into
your empathy
so when you speak about the trees though
you might not be climbing them and
having that goal to do it
you're just feeling that connectedness
that you just mentioned
that we are all one and we're all energy
but you're you're now you have this
depth of empathy
so um whether it's trees or you're
experiencing it in other relationships
and other things you
you're feeling it to a whole new level i
remember what you told me a long time
ago
this was um i think
this is probably after my three
lifetimes ago relationship ended
and i was like everything is brighter
like the flowers are more colorful
the trees are more green and you said it
it never left me
because this is obviously a really long
time ago you said
you're starting to see things through
god's eyes
like through sources eyes you're
starting to see things from
there and i was like huh and so as i
you know anyway so i think that's kind
of also what we're what if you
like tap into that connectedness idea of
everything
like that's and we're all energy the
highest form of source energy or god or
whatever you want to call it and so
like everything does get more real and
raw
as it is and so um feels just been
overwhelming
it's been it's it's it's anybody that's
going down that road or has been on that
path
i mean it's um it's just a lot
it's a lot to handle and there's a like
you you know
understanding what to do with it how to
deal with it
um and then just simply for me just
learning how to feel into it so
also for me something that's also
happened with feelings is that
you know i actually get and and i don't
know
this resonates with other people but i
will get a feeling in my body
and you know for me it's in my solar
plexus but maybe someone else it might
be your heart or it might be your sacral
or maybe it's in your throat like people
that have a hard time like maybe with
your voice or like
you know something there you know
headaches whatever it is whatever chakra
in your body is sort of lighting up for
whatever one lights up for you most but
for me it's always the solar plexus
and i'm not an expert on this by any
means but each one of them i think might
have a little bit more of a different
directive like
maybe fear comes more from the solar
plexus and like you know sadness comes
from the heart i
i'm not sure but that might also be a
way to know but
but i'll get a really big indication in
my body and i'll
feel a lot of discomfort so for me it'll
sort of materialize as
a knot in my stomach or um
difficulty digesting things or um then
at the
most extreme like nausea and the
inability to like
stand up where it's that bad and so
that you know that's like that's been
happening to me for a while where you
get that
um you get a feeling in your body and
then it arrives in my mind and there's
like no fixing that from
it seems like it seems like that's how
it works for me i feel it in my body
before i know it in my mind and so
um that's another that's another
indicator in the feel world
but you know i think also like
to to sort of turn a little bit is
i believe that
we're a lot a lot of us and i'm included
and i don't think anybody wants to cry
right like nobody really wants to like
cry or be super vulnerable in that way
but um i've made a real good piece with
crying i'm a real good crier now
and i enjoy crying but my name's boo-boo
so you know that so like i mean i love
crying but
but um yeah and i know for you you're
learning how to
be comfortable with crying and allow
yourself i don't want to like totally
pivot but i wanted to go back to you
talking about how you feel at first and
then it goes to your mind and the
visceral reactions that you're having
when you're in those moments what do you
then do
what comes up for you well it was very
confusing at first
um you know i'm sure you can remember
times in the past where i'm like i don't
know i feel like i i ate a strawberry
and i feel like i'm gonna like
die right now and um so
now when it happens in fact it happened
the other day
and i was in this very room and
i i got this knot in my stomach and i
had
ate nothing weird and i think that's the
part of it too
is that when you get that connected with
your body and you're that you know
conscious of what you put into it which
you are you get it you you know when
it's
random because you're like yeah i ate
that
i've ate that about 7 000 times and i've
never felt like this so
anyway i was feeling this super big not
my stomach and so i just went
as it came on i was like okay
okay well i know what you are i know
what you are and
so then i was just kind of like you kind
of like surrender to the feeling and
know that something might be coming and
you just go
all right well i'm i'm ready for
whenever that wants to come through and
so
i was in this room and i was doing
something on the floor i was organizing
some drawers in here
and my fancy little office and
i felt so horrible that i had to lay
down and as i just kind of laid down and
actually i'm not i'm not i don't i
didn't get a big download of information
at that very moment before it passed but
i just
allowed myself the ability to
rest and you know resting resting is
i'm really shitty at resting too like
really bad at that
um so i changed that narrative because
you just did it yeah and i just
wow you were in a busy state and you
took time to
you felt something you paused you
allowed it
to express itself and then you
surrendered
and you rested that's huge
so i just forgot that it's beautiful
thank you for sharing this because this
is an
a very good experience and articulation
of how to tap into feeling
in the body when something's coming
through
so i mean i i mean it's almost hard to
know exactly
like because i've had so much come
through like this has been
the best and worst summer of my entire
life and i've experienced like such
extreme duality with emotions
um all the way from like the deepest
sadness to like
greatest joy in the simplest things more
much more often
and so um you know did anything come
through it could have come through
within the days after
because i did actually have a couple of
downloads within the next couple days
with some of the other practices i have
so maybe just it was like a
you know me allowing my body to just
kind of rest in that moment
instead of pushing through something was
a little lesson
little lesson from the universe because
what you resist persists
and so um so i rested and it felt better
but that's like
that i mean yeah so what can i i mean
yeah
that's what happened that was the most
recent time um
but you know you just i'm getting better
at understanding what it means in
surrendering so
yes you know you kind of ask what comes
up for me is that i'm doing a better
job of instead of pushing through and i
i'll go in so another option for someone
that might have this happen
is uh journaling or
meditating or nature walk like
something that allows you to really have
like better space
um meaning from other people and
obligations so that you can
kind of give yourself enough time for it
to come through
yeah i've been quiet yeah i'm getting
into where you're not having the
distractions
um and it also takes a while to calm our
mind down
and our subconscious and like to get
everything
like to get into that consciousness
space is what you're talking about with
meditating being in nature journaling
those are like three beautiful
must that that if you're looking to tune
in to really feeling in that way or a
yes
there's another one that i've started
doing and as you know you told me to do
it and another friend told me to do it
and it's the class
and um yeah so tarantula one yeah
tarantumi
um started that a long time ago and so
you told me to do that
back it's so funny here's a good example
of you totally feeling so
you're telling steph and i about the
class and you're like oh my god
you've got to watch this video and it's
like so emotional you're like i
cried when i watched it and you were
trying to find this video and trying to
find this video and
i think you felt like you found it and
steph and i after you walked away maybe
you went to the bathroom or something we
looked at each other and we were like
what's wrong with her there was nothing
sad about that video
at all and i came out i actually think i
went to go shower and i came back
out and you as you do so beautifully you
just share the truth right like there's
there's
you just share so and you're like yep
i didn't get anything from that i don't
know what it was must be you and your
feeling thing or whatever and
no i don't think i did it was later on
when i had done it that you go
oh my gosh that's what i was telling you
to do because i forgot you told me
because it just didn't register right it
wasn't um
and so this is also a little like like
side note is that
when you have something happen as an
observation
and you think about it but then you
connect it with then there's a feeling
connected with it so
for you you saw it you felt something
and felt emotional so you didn't forget
but you said it and then we watched it
there was no feeling connected it was
just
it was just like cognitive information
but not reside
didn't get into the body didn't get in
and so i forgot that you said it
and so um and that's also a trauma is
too like people get scared of that word
but
trauma being like when something happens
that you have a big feeling or
correlated with it well
when it's a bad thing then as you go
through life anything that happens that
sort of
triggers that that memory that go then
you'll go to that feeling and it's as if
you're stuck at that age so
you know that's a little thing too if
you see somebody reacting in a really
childish way to something
you'll go oh wow they have a trauma when
they were let me guess uh
six i don't know because they're acting
like a toddler
um an adolescent so anyway um but that's
all trauma is too is just like a thought
that goes that goes into the body as a
feeling
and then it gets stuck and stored there
it's just stuck stuck energy
and um and so uh then it was later on
that i'd actually done the class
and i had told you about it forgot that
you had mentioned it and you said that's
what i was telling
you about and you said i must have been
feeling into what the power of the class
was
and what they offer and what it brings
out in people
that uh that it act that i um was
emotional
you were emotional yeah so i cried
watching just like their like little
10-minute yeah promo for it and i was
like
i mean it was and as i'm now like
allowing myself to really be in that
space of feeling
and um it is so much more intense than i
ever even remember
it being and so that's a really good
example of it and it was a it was
actually a really beautiful reflection
just to see
the difference you know we're always
being offered opportunities
to reflect back and and to have tests
and i remember in that i was like that
must have been what it was
because that also helps me tune in a
little bit more to
sure being it's just bringing an
awareness sure so it's so natural for me
that i'm not
it's kind of like right it's like truth
for me like i can't it's like
same thing like when it's your gift and
when it's in your nature to know
something to just
know like you have the feeling it's not
something you make you effort for
like i don't effort to know the truth
it's just kind of a knowing and an
awareness exactly
that it gets really hard that if people
can help you sort of contribute just
like that to say like
yeah that didn't seem very emotional and
then i go and do the class and i tell
you about it
you're like gosh thank you because you
know um so anyway the only thing that
i'll say the other
so the last thing i'll mention here
about this sort of topic of feel
is that um i'm realizing two and this
next
this is sort of like a new new element
to help me
get to a feeling get to an awareness get
to a knowing get to information
is um this sort of somatic
element of a voice
of of using your voice of of audible
sounds so yeah for anybody who's done
the class
you know exactly what i'm talking about
but if you don't
then it's basically you you know you'll
be moving
and you know allowing yourself to add
some voice in it like
actually i'll tell you here's that
here's it the class does it
but it would this happened to me with
dusty in massage which you know
we both know dusty and so she gets into
this she does somatic healing but she
also
um does body work and so um which you
referred me to her as well and
so i went in there uh sort of at the
beginning of like
all of my horrible summer activities
and um i went in for a massage
and she's like i was kind of telling her
something's going on
and you know she's like okay she's like
well we'll just see what comes through
and so i and she's like you know if
something happens or something comes
through
just i keep working so just stick with
it and i'm like okay
which is fine for me i'm like pretty
decent pretty good with all the whole
emotion
crap now and so especially when it's
just girls and
you know someone you know so i'm laying
on the table and she gets to the spot on
my back
that i keep in mind it's stuck energy
i've got this spot on my back and she
can't get through it and she keeps
working and working and working
and sure it's still there and i can feel
it i can feel what she's working on
and she goes at some point in time after
doing some sounds which is like this is
where it gets into the little bit of the
hippie round for people
um so matic is too but she'll start to
like she used like
um like a didgeridoo or like chimes or
drums or something like that or bowls
sound bowls or something like that which
is what these are
um so can you hear them buzzing as we
talk they're actually lighting up um so
anyway it's our energy
um so she goes give this
give this spot a sound
and so at first i kind of made a sound
and i was like
you know it's awkward but you're like it
is yeah i'm like i'm like
ah you know and then i was like ah and
she's and so then i i
i just felt something more coming and
then all of a sudden it was like
you know much bigger it was like ah you
know and like a really big
sound and as soon as i did that i
started bawling
so that's an example of like adding a
little bit of
sound to um to uh
to to the to your practice to just sort
of like
really like give yourself some private
space where you can just kind of be
be ridiculous and feel really
uncomfortable and then you just kind of
are just like
you just like whatever you're doing like
maybe make some movements or even just
sit there and just
ah like whatever comes through for
like just give your let your body sound
how it wants to
sound and what i've noticed with the
class as i do it more of a
as a practice now is that it's almost
like the door that
unlocks the emotion and it basically
like
oh it makes it available very available
it like brings it right out yeah and so
you give it some sound
opens the door and then you stick with
it and then all of a sudden
like i i like i might cry i usually cry
and then there's but there's an
awareness there's like a
there's like a really simple sort of
statement that comes through her thought
where i'm like
ah you know like that's what needed to
come out
well when you also open
and you're creating more space as we
vocalize and we're moving energy through
our body
we're also allowing more to be able to
receive
in our body so it's it's interesting you
know for all the workouts you've
done um that are
incredible and to have it at this level
where they're doing it where it's very
unstructured it's more of this fluid
movement but
it allows the voice to come i'm curious
for you
how do you feel different from because
you get endorphins with both right
for sure you're traditional but with
this one what how does that feel for you
what's the difference between between
working out
and breathing heavy and making noise at
times versus
um one of them
well it's that i'm allowing myself
i'm allowing my body to express itself
without any structure so there you go
yeah so like with a workout there's like
something next to do
right and so you kind of know like oh
this is hard you're like
but with that you know you're
it's allowing thing it's allowing your
body to not only
sound but move in a way that's
you would never want someone to
videotape whatever
you would just want them you'd want no
one to see what you're doing or hear
what you're doing
um so it's like truly
truly truly your body's pure
expression and so uh it's like you're
tapping into more of your authenticity
which then probably peels away to the
truth to the emotion
and allows it to come through beautiful
thank you
let's feel let's see thanks everybody
for listening to the pretty intense
podcast today i hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click
on the subscribe button